yes good morning everybody welcome to
another edition of the gratitude journal
live stream coming at you number 38
super pumped to be here again today
happy Wednesday midway through the week
well sad they were midway through the
week I love the work week I love the
work week people people see this hump
day and ready for the end of the week
but I love the work quick i love the
work week I love what I do you're gonna
love what you do so today we're talking
about three things that we're good
before I'm going to share mine two
things at iron grip before for today you
guys share yours in a live chat Bose
you're watching afterwards leave it down
below it's important that was a daily
consistent habit and that you really
think about why your for those things if
you want to have the lasting benefits so
today my three things are going to be
number one it's Wednesday and I'm
grateful for video day I'm getting for
everyone's if your video day I have an i
have a daily I have a weekly schedule
every day I do something different and
it's consistent so when's is my video de
um you know thursday is my public facing
day media interviews hangouts you know
all that kind of stuff and there's
enough variety every week did i miss it
and i look forward to it I look forward
to today I look forward to wednesday
look forward to after today like ah
when's the next video day and it's a
full week ahead and so I like having a
little bit in my schedule that I kind of
Miss and look forward to and I try to
remind myself every Wednesday that this
this is an important day because I'm off
making content that is going to reach
potentially millions of people and even
if you're not making something that's
reaching millions of people yet having
that intent like you can break out at
any time you get your breakout could be
the next piece of content you make your
breakup could be the next interview you
do your breakup can be the next product
that you put out there and so putting
the love and the work and the energy and
the effort into it I think it's
important
you know I make my top 10 videos with
the thought process that that person is
going to watch it and want to share it
and it's happened before tapping a
number of times and there's been a
couple times when I was not happy with
the first version of it and so i redid
it because I'm also thinking about that
person like if they saw would they share
and so are you creating your work with
the expectation that millions of people
going to see it that might increase the
level of importance that might increase
the level of hustle and energy and love
you pour into it you're only one next
great piece away from making your big
break out and so that's the mindset I
come in every Wednesday before I film
like today's a day today is a day that
people are going to see my content it's
going to blow up I mean we've already
blown up but really blow up right we're
gonna get 25 million subscribers and 10
million subscribers and have had this be
a daily ritual for for a lot of people
so having that mindset I find helps and
so I'm grateful for video day Wednesday
yes uh cool number two I was thinking
this morning about my trip to China I
wanted to two years ago and then i read
a there's a big pollution problem in
china and everybody's wearing masks and
we had to wear these masks i had these
special filters on it so you don't
especially in beijing so you don't have
the pollutants coming to your nose and i
was reading the article when i came back
about them selling Canadian Air bottled
Canadian Air to China for a breath of
fresh air I guess and I just thought
that's crazy but also I'm super grateful
for the air that i get to bring it right
there boggling their bottling this air
right here this is the area that they're
bobbling you know I get that I get to
breed that every day which again like a
lot of times the things that we take for
granted we
be aware of and recognize so I'm super
grateful that I have some quality
canadian air to breathe in every day on
the number 3 i'm going to say this this
opportunity here with you guys i look
forward to gratitude live stream
everyday i look forward to the schedule
i love seeing what you're grateful for
because it always puts something else
most of the time on my mind that maybe I
should be grateful for two things that
I've missed things that I haven't been
you know aware of and I love seeing what
you guys are grateful for and I love
this process in this experiment every
day so thank you guys for that
opportunity to so those are mine those
are the things I'm greet before I want
to get to the live chat see what's up
there and see what you guys are good
before so leave it in the comments zeno
hey believe nation we didn't get before
today he's got number one a nice warm
shower I agree I just got with a shower
still a little wet there I like a warm
shower I'm a hot shower kind of guy I
like thinking in the shower tube not in
the morning ones usually like an evening
shower like after they've crazy and
working out you know I have a good like
20 minute shower in its part shower part
meditation on the things that have
transpired today and get my brain going
so I like the warm shower number to
believe nation for its love support and
all around awesomeness I agree a hundred
percent I love you guys to thank you for
that recognition say no and number three
being able to get over frustrating
moments more quickly than before that's
interesting i love that i wonder what
sparked the change I wonder what sparked
the change one of the things that I'm
having the team my team do more and more
I'm bringing more people into this group
that i have is making them watch the top
10 videos daily because I I I contribute
a lot of the I attributes are a lot of
the success and mindset shifts and
increase
evidence and just the growth that I've
had over the past couple years to doing
all the work that I do research and
famous entrepreneurs and putting them
together in the top 10 videos watching
so it's one thing to like if you don't
have confidence right that's one thing
to read a book about confidence one
thing to follow here the seven ways to
be more confident can definitely work
but I think it's also important to see
confidence to be around confidence to be
around greatness right we've talked
about it a number of times and if you
can see people being confident
consistently some of it rubs off on you
like you can't help but some of it like
seeps into your system a little bit and
so seeing these great entrepreneurs and
innovators and athletes and musicians
and their confidence and their their
strive for greatness a little extra rubs
into me and there's a motivation as we
could call tremendous Jones who said
that your your level of success how much
you earn will be the same in five years
as it is today apart from the people you
meet and the books that you read that's
pretty powerful and I would add in the
videos that you watch too it kind of
comes from a pre YouTube different era
so I'm curious you know what what led to
that you've been looking over
frustrating moments more quickly moving
on Jer I cycled for bags that make it
easy to carry things see I love it bags
and make it easy to carry things one
hundred percent for Tesla releasing
genius innovations those tiles are crazy
if you guys haven't seen the solar tiles
a test looking up with their nuts I love
it for concrete which makes clear solid
roads and showers too I love it all
right there's a shower shower trend
happen today sweater hello beautiful
people on the kuru hi family Rishi Cup
TV couple love for and yay for video de
sky's the limit great rising everyone
there it is again people for life nature
and opportunities I love that the key
route think thankful
for being home alone right now a little
downtime little nilda kiru time for
being me how many you guys really feel
grateful for being you what's a good one
I like that and being an answer to many
relationships and women I love that oh
that's good sweat on people for people
around me who encouraged me to do things
by myself I love that new feature build
a good morning much hey y'all joining
from LA I love it much as is thankful
for a long time friends that I can
always giggle with even after I haven't
seen them in years I love that it's
great sunny and beautiful in LA love
that people are loving the long showers
the queue I what I think I'm the only
one from Ukraine here makes me feel more
special I love that what else we have
shweta I love this family this motivates
me to refresh me as I get this after
630pm in my country I love that much I'm
grateful for video capabilities on my
phone so I can film for youtube and send
silly snaps to my friends and family I
love that thank you guys for joining
this nine ten that's it it's crazy how
quickly 10 minutes goes I hope you guys
have an amazing day we're going to hop
off to twitch to play a game of League
of Legends and answer your business
questions with my usual co-host we she
kept TV and Ji so join us there if not
how an amazing day I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
guys I'll see you soon